next is Kathy in San Francisco hi Kathy
how are you hi Dave I'm doing well and
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up well about 26 months ago
I put the brakes on and started to look
at my life in the debt that I was in and
I realized that I had to get moving to
get rid of it and so I read the Total
Money Makeover I picked up another job
tutoring I'm a schoolteacher I've taught
for about 20 years and I really got
focused and I wanted to be a good role
model for my children and I paid off
forty-eight thousand four hundred eighty
three dollars and 73 cents which was a
brand-new car credit cards and monies
for the kids for school Wow
so I got that done but now my question
is I live out here in California and I
have a house payment that's about that's
two thousand two dollars per month and I
take home regularly about forty three
hundred a month how did you pay off
forty eight thousand dollars in debt
extra money above that at that time i
tutored just around the clock I just
worked numerous hours okay to do that
well you're gonna be tutoring if you
keep this house right no and I just you
know what Dave I'm sixty and I don't
want to keep doing that maybe not around
the clock but there's just I mean I
understand California real estate San
Francisco real estate in particular is
unbelievably expensive right and that
there's a reality of that and people
often ask me the question if they're in
Manhattan or LA or San Fran you know
well Dave I mean do I get a pass no I
mean California is not exempt from math
even though it feels like it out there
with the dadgum house prices but still
at the end the day after you pay your
house payments you're poorer every month
every month you're happy more yeah and
how poor is no fun it's not fun and I so
my plan my goal for myself is hopefully
to work five more years and so I wonder
do I sell it and rent for five years do
I sell it and try to buy something
smaller
where are you going to live after
retirement right you know what I'll
probably end up out here even though I
don't really want to be in California
I'm a little confused now why would you
say if you don't want to be there my
kids are here oh okay okay and grandkids
more importantly they would probably
yeah yeah if they believe well but you
can't retire in this with this house
payment right no I could not retire with
this house payment so I got to go either
way
the house has to go right yeah with this
income either the incomes got to go up
or the out guy who's got to go down and
that's what that's a fixed math equation
that we're just all stuck with and so
right yeah so I guess I'm moving down in
house that I'm gonna live in in
retirement okay I know you think look
and maybe purchase a smaller house if I
okay now something less expensive and
that you can afford and that doesn't
make you house poor and with the idea
that we're gonna be able to afford it in
retirement and be eventually get it paid
off even in retirement right we got to
move in that general direction but yes
if you want to stay in the area let's go
ahead and do that now and create a
better living environment for you now
and then you know more opportunity to
save now because you make that move now
and it might just be a little condo or
something that fits your lifestyle this
is the Dave Ramsey show